stop making excuses you're the only one
stopping eating to create something from
the ground up and to be able to you know
kind of walking or purpose is a great
feeling I was just saying kind of yes
woman like yeah okay I'll fix it I'll
I'll figure it out okay no problem and I
kind of lost what I was trying to say in
the process because I was trying to make
what they wanted me to make what's that
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
in your potential and I want to see that
thing that you've got inside you explode
out into the world to have a big impact
for you your family and the world so to
help you in your journey today we're
going to learn from actress writer and
producer Issa Rae and my take on her top
ten rules for success rule number one is
my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys like the best
and as always guys as you're watching if
you hear something that really really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired and
when you write it down it's much more
likely to stick for yourself as well
enjoy
graduated from Stanford studied African
American Studies and political science
was heavy into directing and producing
plays at school and then I created my
first web series my senior year
eventually moved back to LA and just
started doing all these odd jobs and
trying to establish myself as the
videographer or an editor and trying to
get worked that way and hopefully by
like in my mind my filming weddings and
filming you know talents the high school
talent shows I'd be discovered by a film
director who'd be like wow you really
filmed that wedding nicely but that
wasn't the case J oh my god that issue
wow I haven't seen you since college
right this is where people who major in
african-american studies end up sweetie
I'd started a black film blog I was
super into film I still am the same
types of black movies were coming out
with the same types of type of humor and
it was frustrating and I was voicing
that on my blog and I remember one
comment was like you complain so much
why don't you make something and that
like I was like oh well okay I will
Rolling Stone in New York Times reviewed
our show Shonda Rhimes and Shawn Ellen
caught wind of the show and asked me to
come in for a meeting and I picked them
a show just in ingest basically called I
hate la do's you know it was very true
to my heart and it was true to their
heart
they're like oh my god we hey LM in two
and let's do this show and I was like
this is great thank you
trash GLA man and then developed that
shot with them and something I learned
was just like I was I felt like this was
my one shot and I like I I was extremely
I say all the time eager to please and
Shana Milan they were great just in
terms of recognizing that I'd never
written it like TV show before and we're
great about hand-holding but I think
where I fell short was just navigating
Network notes and for me you know there
was a network and then there was a
studio that chimes in and of course Sean
Elaine but I was working with them
closely so we were on the same page but
when the studio network would give notes
I was just saying kind of yes woman like
yeah okay I'll fix it I said I'll figure
it out okay no problem and I kind of
lost what I was trying to say in the
process because I was trying to make
what they wanted me to make and I think
they want you to just do you they want
you to funnel their notes through your
voice and I didn't get that at the at
the time and so they ended up passing on
that series after I wrote the pilot and
you know I was devastated and was like I
blew my one shot and then a month later
HBO called and they were like hey we
heard you're free do you have any ideas
for us and that lesson I'll take that
call please yeah I have lots of ideas
and that really helped me to learn like
I was like I'll never like just dilute
my voice again like this is why they
hired me and I had to kind of learn like
I'm here for a reason I have something
to say and that's why they called me in
the first place advice that I would give
to people is just to
stop making excuses you're the only one
stopping you because I have to hear that
myself like cuz I like I'm excuse Queen
I'm procrastinating Queen I'm I'm all of
those and like I would always talk about
how I wanted to make this happen I
wanted to to put a show out I wanted to
make this idea happen and I want to be a
writer and a producer but once you're
coming up with ways that you can't do
something you're not gonna do it so I
think that stop finding the ways that
you can't do something and find the ways
all the ways that you can and just go
for it
I was simultaneously building an online
following without knowing it because I
have a genuine love for social media you
know I I get a lot of people come to me
and say how do I get into it you know
how do I use social media to my
advantage and it was it just came from
like I'm always on it like I love being
on Facebook and I remember when Facebook
opened up internationally you know I'm
half Senegalese and I was like oh snap
okay okay that's Nigeria so even that's
there's already a lot of you here so
come on give me Seneca um so there's
like four last names in Senegal
so I was just typing in last names and
friending people like oh yeah we gotta
stick together and I ended up building
like a following from people there and
then in addition to that had like a film
blog and reviewed films and TV shows
just as an avid fan and started building
that audience of course would funnel it
through Facebook and what also just in
in the midst of having legitimate films
and television shows being reviewed I
would slip my own work in there so that
people who were coming from like film
and television news were also seeing my
stuff and you know it was like hit or
miss some people were like that's not
what I came here for and some people
were generally like oh this is pretty
good and so grew it from there so I was
just like tested absolutely what made
her in part to stay in twist that
was really capitalizing on a relatively
new technology and platform to actually
build her brand and a name for herself
and her work and it started with
Facebook randomly trying to add all
friends when I when they opened up to
like the world I was like oh my gosh I'm
gonna add all the Senegalese people
because they're like three last names
I'll do is type the last names and you
know whatever so that was like a
community I created like an African
community where we would you know share
stuff amongst each other and three shows
down the line when I launched I for a
black girl like I had accumulated a
fanbase from the other two shows and
really learned from my mistakes learn
what people wanted to see them studying
like analytics and by the time that show
was put out like there was an audience
it wasn't like huge or anything but it
was enough for them to share with their
friends and they would share with their
friends she put that first episode out I
don't think we knew how many people were
gonna like it
but a lot of people just jumped on and
all of a sudden it just blew up
I saw Natalie the flow of this video she
had a conformed okay and I was I just
thought she was so beautiful and I was
also working at a job that I was
frustrated with and trying to get
awkward blood girl off the ground I've
tweeted something like man I wish I had
an excuse like I wish someone would just
break up with me so that I could have an
excuse to shave my hair off and then I
was like oh that's a funny plot line of
like a show or something and decided
like to tweet that I was gonna or put on
Facebook that I wanted to shave my head
bald and so all my friends responded
like oh my gosh do it you got to be so
ugly oh my god what if you have a
weird-shaped head and I was like my
friends are terrible but I saw how much
attention I was getting and I was like
oh my gosh I should use this I should
shave my head and then do a trailer for
awkward black girl where I I feature my
bald head and that way people who want
to see what I look like will also know
about this new show that I'm trying to
do where does your confidence come from
my confidence comes from doing what I
love to be honest like to be able to
create something from the ground
and to be able to you know kind of
walking or purpose is a great feeling
like like I feel validated in having
gotten you know to this point and it's
like seeing where I can go from here and
then of course you know I love my
friends I have a great group of friends
that gave me confidence and who also
simultaneously keep me grounded just
like yo you're not that time you're good
but you calm down you know and I love
that and la gives me confidence being
here like trying to start my career in
New York it was humbling you know in a
way cuz I always wanted to be there
that's stupid March maybe you can make
it here you can make it everywhere like
was always in the back of my mind and
you know I struggled there for awhile
but I was like happily struggling until
I got to a point where someone kind of
told me the the cliff was under me like
girl you know you're you're like in like
struggling struggling super broke you're
like you just got robbed like you're
doing the most thing you don't have to
be if you come back to LA you'll be okay
and everybody you know is here and I
didn't realize how much of a confidence
booster it is to be in your hometown
we haven't know so many people where
your family's here where your friends
are here and it just feels easier if it
makes sense for you to quit your job and
you know you're you're 100% confident in
what you're doing then didn't do it but
don't just go on a whim and be like hey
my job or this idea that I'm just
starting and I'm not too sure about I
think that if you can find a way to
balance both because if you love
something you're gonna make time for it
so if you're not if you're just quitting
to make time for something that you're
unsure whether or not you'll be able to
fully commit to
that's not a good idea but if you're
passionate you know that you're
committed to making something happening
your job is standing in the way so stop
trying so hard to be someone you're not
stop trying so hard period you don't
have to I remember
constantly feeling like I wasn't I
wasn't what was expected of me and a lot
of that had to do with my skin color I
love that it feels so stupid but a lot
of it feels I had to do with not feeling
black enough like I was the right kind
of black like I wasn't cool enough like
I wasn't fun enough like I wasn't I just
wasn't good enough or what what was
being painted of me just even on
television and music and that was really
disheartening and I would tell my
younger self now that you don't need to
be that it's totally fine like
everything's gonna be okay and I
honestly embrace who you are now embrace
what makes you different you don't have
people don't have to if people don't
like you for who you are and then those
people aren't meant to be in your life
you don't want them there anyway
so stop trying to impress people by
being someone you're not after awkward
black girl during awkward black girl you
know I was producing that pretty much
out of pocket and my pockets were empty
so that was hard and I was fortunate
enough to once I produce the first
episode and I produced it for $25 and
that was $25 to take my $5 like where
did you know but food it was food it was
to be tacos for everyone and so they
were just generous enough to support
their time and they knew that I just
didn't have the funds and they were just
down to the cause and then as we
continue to grow you know one of my
producing partners from was a writing
partner from college and she came on
board and was like let me help
and get my USC crew to work for free and
then you know they were working for free
and then after a while you feel guilty
just as a creative asking people to
donate their time
when you know there's exposure and
things like that so we've just felt like
we needed to have something to give
people who were working 18-hour days for
us and so we started a Kickstarter and
that was you know we set a goal of
30,000 and ended up raising close to
sixty and then that was a start of just
the media being aware of us and Pharrell
contacted us you know in the middle of
our season and asked if he could you
know fund the second season and that
ended up changing the game this is a
huge full circle moment for me because
you know this is my favorite event to
come to us Avis said it's such a genuine
like real event it's the only one my
publicist doesn't have to to force me to
go to and it's also the first event
where I walked a red carpet and I
remember the day distinctly it was four
years ago and I was fresh off of I think
season two of awkward black girl and I
was already nervous because I had to go
to the event by myself which awkward
black girls don't like to do and my
publicist Vanessa shoutout to you girl
she was like if you do anything you
better walk that damn carpet
and I didn't know what to expect but I
knew I had a specific task you know so I
had to go and I remember arriving and
standing in the red carpet line and the
woman in front of me turned around and
it was the nightly thing y'all so San I
turned and she smiled at me but I look
down and instead of saying something
I immediately text my younger brother
and my sister because I knew they'd
understand and my brother wrote
something back like did you tell you did
you tell her you a lesbian just for her
and my sister wrote something back like
say something to her so I put my phone
down and I start you know and I walked
the hell out of that line because I did
not belong there I was not about to be
anybody's red carpet line so when I got
back in line tonight I had already
passed through so I stood there by
myself and scrolled through my phone
which is an awkward girl defense
mechanism and I looked up for a moment
and I met eyes with niecy Nash who I
loved from Reno 9-1-1 at the time and
she was in the front of the line and she
winked at me and waved and I looked at
her like you gave me an encouraging look
like hey I feel you I did not feel like
I'm alone so I got to the red carpet and
I was ready I gave the carpet publicist
I think that's what they're called the
people that asked you for your name and
they shot
I did the carpet publicist my name and
he announced he's alright everybody and
I took a deep breath and then I stepped
onto the carpet to stand on my head
ready for the cameras and no sooner than
five seconds that I stepped on the
carpet did what I heard Oh golly and
everybody turned the camera and they all
turn to this gorgeous goddess and I
stood in the middle of the carpet like
not sure what to do until a kind
photographer helped me and he said hey
can you move I'm trying to get Leila if
you look at the footage from five years
ago you can see me in the background of
somebody's interview asking to know what
in particular what are you well you
should act like other people look stupid
but you brother
Oh
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because sunshine Shauna
asked me to if there's someone you'd
like me to cover in a future top ten
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote I'd also love
to know what did you learn from this
video what lesson really hit home the
hardest what are you going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
or to your business leave it down the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Steph reference Steph thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word taking that picture
posted online it's great to see you at
the cafe cracking open the book
hopefully you're getting tons of value
from it and I really appreciate your
support thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
what's the best career advice someone
has given you that was the best advice I
was being soft I was in my feeling and a
girl was just like stop at the song like
bones not be about fiction that was the
best thing ever I think it's what you
learn out of failure in there a lot of
failures like I can't go a day without
feeling something but it's just like
what you what you take from you and like
that's I think where I thrive is just
like okay I'm not gonna make that
mistake that same way again how can I
use that
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple so
it would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]